j'aime médecin vient d'évoquer la radio
et la télévision et ce soit on peut se
demander si nous n'allons pas assister
un nouvel épisode de la guerre des ondes
radiophoniques dans notre région par
exemple la bande des mecs vous savez
cette fameuse modulation de fréquence
arrive pratiquement à saturation avec
plus d'une trentaine de radios
certaines sont autorisés d'autres ne le
sont pas mais elle les met tout de même
et la haute autorité dans tout ça direz
vous eh bien elle pourrait bien se
fâcher en effet jeudi prochain elle
examinera le dossier des radios qui ne
respectent pas la loi en attendant jean
crozier et mario marque et sont repartis
eux sur ce front de la guerre des ondes
depuis la légalisation des radios
privées ça coince drôlement sur la bande
fm
celle ci est en effet l'objet de
nouvelles convoitises la guerre des
ondes est d'autant plus farouches
qu'avec la publicité une fréquence ça
peut aussi rapporter de l'argent sur la
côte d'azur le brouillage est telle
qu'ils portent même atteinte au confort
d'écouté des émissions du service public
à moins de se placer directement sous
les émetteurs de télédiffusion de france
nous l'avons vu il est extrêmement
difficile de suivre un programme de
radio and entier les raisons de cet
embouteillage sont simples pour le seul
département des alpes-maritimes ou en
février 80 de la haute autorité a
autorisé 13 stations de radio il y a à
ce jour 16 radios qui émettent sans
autorisation les choses ne vont pas du
tout s'arrange et il y a à ce jour 17
projets déposés à la préfecture des
alpes-maritimes
les nouvelles décisions de la haute
autorité et la volonté récemment affirmé
par la direction de radio france d'avoir
systématiquement recours à la justice
protégeront peut-être après le droit
d'émettre le droit d'écouter des mesures
s'imposent en effet sur le marché noir
des ondes la vente clandestine des
fréquences se développe et les enchères
commencent à plus de 50 millions de
centimes
on est très loin des radios libres